Agreeable young woman to
be more disagreeable and
assertive if that isn't how
she is temperamentally inclined.
Oh,
that's a good question.
And I would say first of all,
that's a very common question that
people who go into psychotherapy ask.
I think the most common problem that
psychotherapists deal with apart from
anxiety and depression is
probably assertiveness training.
Um,
so the first thing I would say is you
really need to figure out what you want.
And I would recommend doing
the self authoring program,
the future authoring program in particular
because if you want to stand up for
yourself,
you have to have your goals and your
vision well laid out and well defined.
And then you have to have a strategy,
um,
that that is matched to
those goals so that you can,
so that you know what you want so that
you know when you're not getting it it
otherwise you're left with a vague
sense of dissatisfaction and resentment.
And that's very,
very difficult thing to articulate.
And if you can't articulate it,
then you can't negotiate.
If you know what you
want and you know why,
then you can make a case for yourself.
Okay.
So let's assume now that you've laid
out a vision and a counter vision,
which the future authoring
program also helps you do.
So you know what kind of hell you want
to avoid that you might drift into if you
were to agreeable for
the rest of your life.
And that would be a hell that consisted
mostly of people taking advantage of you
all the time and you feeling
resentful and bitter about it.
Not something I would recommend.
Um,
see,
I think that women are agreeable
because it helps them deal with infants,
but it's not a great temperamental
strategy for dealing with complex,
um,
organizations in,
in the adult world.
So I think it's a price
that women pay for.
Also being adapted to have plenty
of patients for very young children.
And then you have to overcome that to
some degree to put yourself forward
properly in more complex
hierarchies of accomplishment.
So I would say once you have
your vision established,
your vision for the future
and your counter vision,
so you're afraid of what will happen.
If you don't stand up for yourself,
then you need to consult
your resentment fic.
Because if you're
resentful about something,
as far as I can tell,
there's generally only two reasons.
One is you should grow the
hell up and quit whining,
so you've got to find out first.
If you're just feeling sorry for
yourself and you can think that through,
make a pro and con case and you can talk
to somebody that you care about about
that.
I'm not assuming that that's the reason,
but that's one potential reason.
If you're not merely
feeling sorry for yourself,
then you probably have something to say
and something that you need and you need
to figure out what that is and then you
have to develop a strategy to to put
that forward.
I've seen lots of people in my personal
life and in my private practice not get
what they want because well a,
they don't specify it and
they don't ask for it.
And if you're negotiating save for a
raise or for a promotion and so forth,
you have to put yourself forward.
You need to tell your the
person you're working for,
why you should be treated with more
consideration or respect or have more
resources devoted to
you or more authority.
Um,
what shifted to you?
And you have to make a case for that.
A compelling case so that they
have a reason to attend to you.
And that's not good.
They're not going to notice because most
managerial types are so overloaded with
work that they never noticed
when anything's going right.
They just notice the things
that are going wrong.
So you need to make a plan,
you have to have a strategy
that goes along with that plan.
You have to have articulated arguments
for why certain a certain form of
treatment is appropriate to you.
And then you have to have the
courage to put that forward.
And I guess you have to remember that
you owe yourself as much as you owe other
people.
You have to take care of yourself,
like you take care of other people and,
and that's a moral duty
and if you practice that,
you can do it.
And a lot of that,
a lot of that is also associated
with telling the truth.
You know,
you don't have a better
friend than the truth,
even though it can be very
harsh in the short term.
And so if you're unhappy at work
because you're being taken advantage of,
then you have to strategize yourself
out of that and you have to learn to
negotiate.
And a lot of that also means that you
have to overcome your hesitancy to engage
in conflict.
And you've got to think about it this way.
Negotiation and conflict are somewhat
indistinguishable and it's easy moment to
moment to avoid negotiation conflict,
but you pay a terrible price for
it in the medium to long term.
It's better to face the
conflict forthrightly in the
present and make peace for
the medium to long term.
And that there's courage in that.
So that's the other thing I would
say is gird up your loins and,
and,
and allow yourself to act courageously,
courageously.
And truthfully,
truth is your best bet
if you're too agreeable.
So you know,
you also might find that you have a
pretty good critical intelligence,
but that you think it's mean
and so that you keep it hidden.
Some of the smartest women
I knew who were very,
very agreeable had unbelievably
good instincts with regards
to figuring out what
other people's motives were,
but they were ashamed of their suspicions.
And really what that meant was they
ended up being ashamed of their critical
intelligence because
they were so agreeable.
So it may be that the darker part of you,
the shadow part of you knows things that
you could know if you are willing to
admit that they were true.
And so you have to give
some credence to your,
to your darker element,
I would say.
How do you know if you were communicating
with the actual person or a mask?
I sometimes wonder if I can
ever really know someone.
Well,
you can't ever thoroughly know someone
because people are too complicated.
You can't even really know yourself.
How do you know if you're communicating
with the actual person or a mask?
Well,
if you're communicating
with an actual person,
then you're actually
having a conversation,
you know,
and the conversation transforms as a
consequence of participating in it and it
tends to be engaging in meaningful.
If what's happening is an exchange
of ideological platitudes or or just
platitudes themselves for that matter,
then you probably engaging with the mask.
So if the conversation is compelling and
meaningful and it transforms as it as
it progresses and and you can see that
give and take that dance like give and
take,
then you're communicating
with an actual person.
The other thing I would say is that
when you're communicating with an actual
person rather than a mask,
that person that you're communicating
with tends to be quite interesting.
You know,
if people talk about what they know,
which means you really
communicating with them.
If they talk about their own personal
experience instead of wandering off into
the domain of cliches and
ideological platitudes,
then people tend to be
extraordinarily interesting.
And so that's another good tactic
and a good hint that you're,
that you're where you should
be when you're conversing.
One of the rules I had when I was
seeing clients actively was that if the
conversation I was having
wasn't interesting,
and if my attention started to wonder,
then we weren't discussing issues that
were sufficiently vital because if we
were discussing vital issues,
then the conversation basically flew by,
and so I think that's a good,
that's a good marker.